[Music]
w
is
[Applause]
thank you very very
much my name is codin
O'Brian and I am not in the Hunger Games
films so I know you're very
disappointed yeah I could have been a
guy that lived under Brown for 48
years never exposed to sunlight I am
thrilled to be here are you guys happy
to be
here I'm team Josh I'm
here and I'll fight anyone who
[Applause]
isn't you're going to fight
me oh okay he's actually ready to this
guy is ready to go what what do you team
what do you team
sir you even know do you you don't care
you just wanted to fight
me I don't care I want to kick his
ass I am thrilled to be here ladies and
gentlemen uh for this amazing panel
mocking J part two this is the
panel they said I could do any panel I
wanted to do this one I am really
thrilled to be here they've asked me to
mention just one or two things I first
of all want to welcome you to the
Comic-Con Hall h I think the best Hall h
yeah don't do that uh it's just a letter
and we're going to bring you today of
course talk about part two the Epic
story of Katniss everan and the world of
panm Full Circle this next movie brings
it all around we're all very excited I'm
encouraging fans to hashtag unite and #
mocking J part two # s
DCC I'm middleaged and I don't know what
any of that
means but I'm told you guys know what to
do with that information back slash
delete
okay I mean so over my
head uh okay I've also been told to
remind you that we're not allowed to
shoot anything uh with our phones today
because you're going to be seeing some
pretty incredible groundbreaking amazing
first time ever stuff today but rest
assured rest assured I will be shooting
it all on my
iPhone I will have this on the internet
in 40
minutes and they're calling security now
all right let's get started without
further Ado please welcome the director
of these incredible films Francis
Lawrence let's get Francis Lawrence out
here there he
is let's bring up producers Nina
Jacobson she made it all happen ladies
and gentlemen she brought this franchise
together ladies and gentlemen also the
character that started it all Primrose
everine Willow
Shields District 13 Rebel Warrior Gale
hawthor Liam hensworth
[Applause]
the recently rescued Tia malar
joshers and finally last but certainly
not least the mocking J herself Cav sine
J
yeah we're done thank you good
night that never get rushes forward
never gets old uh welcome everybody
there's so much to talk about thanks all
of you for being here this is very cool
uh I have some questions we're going to
start with nah Jacobson you don't mind
Nina this is a incredible conclusion to
a series that has been years and years
in the making
it's inspired a generation of fans how
do you go about bringing this franchise
to a close with this last film I mean
it's a massive task to bring it all
together what are your
thoughts which I think it's been
emotional for all of us because uh we've
had amazing material from Suzanne
Collins that um has captivated an
enormous amount of attention but also
has a lot to say and uh we want to
deliver on the emotion and on the the
politics of it the the all of the things
that Suzanne has had to say about our
culture we want to deliver on all of
that but we also don't want to say
goodbye to each other and so it's been a
combination of trying to really nail it
and make sure that it is completely
satisfying um to the core in terms of
theme character and story um and enjoy
the time that we have together uh while
we do it
this has got to be emotional for you
because it's been uh as you said it's
been a long experience now you're
bringing it around full circle and you
guys have to kind of say goodbye that's
got to be tough it is tough I think uh
we all wish that there were seven or
eight books not just three uh but if if
we do them Justice and uh say really
bring the emotions home it's a very very
emotional conclusion and it's emotional
for us but I think it's emotional for
audiences and we want to deliver for the
fans they've delivered for us we want to
deliver for them well I have written
hastily a script for a new one and if
you guys are willing to make it yeah I
play a large part in the next one it
will be very unpopular uh Francis
Lawrence uh in this installment the next
one war is fully underway without giving
any incredible spoilers that destroy the
purpose of all this being here can you
tell us what we're going to see in m j
part two uh well I think uh you know
this is where Katniss is kind of gets
back into action uh you know she was a
bit sidelined in the last movie um and
going through some of her issues uh but
this time she's finally going after uh
going after snow and going into the
capital uh with Squad 451 and we get
some real battle footage and uh it's
it's some really exciting stuff okay I'm
told that you brought something very
special for us to see today is that
correct I did don't know yes it's a
picture you took several
hours no you brought something uh that I
think people are going to be very
EXC yes uh we brought the First full
trailer he didn't say he was going to
show
it he just we were looking at it
backstage and it's
awesome uh you guys are the first ones
to see it it has not gone anywhere it
still won't go anywhere for a while
especially if you all if you all put the
phones down please uh so that people can
see high quality versions uh but I'm
really excited to bring it uh to you
guys the fans you guys you know camp out
you wait you guys have been
[Applause]
fantastic so the this is for you guys
enjoy all right uh Francis trailer was
absolutely unbelievable uh and the movie
looks amazing uh this story now takes it
to the next level because the characters
are now above ground and they are
fighting and as we can all see they're
running around uh there are so many
different battlefields what's it like
what does that how does that new
environment influence the story it must
have been fun slash incredibly
complicated to shoot uh yeah I mean it
it was very complicated uh but it was
interesting because we had a big shift
you know when we moved to the capital we
actually moved production from Atlanta
to Europe and a lot of Atlanta was spent
in kind of dank warehouses and spent
kind of in our underground sets and so
to to leave Atlanta and to go to Europe
and shoot on these uh and in these
amazing locations in Paris and Berlin um
create an entirely different environment
for for all of us I think so it was kind
of this breath of fresh air um and you
know the world kind of opened up for us
uh just as it did for the for the
characters but it was tough I mean it it
was grueling there are really difficult
scenes to shoot really strenuous uh
physically and demanding in terms of
focus and uh vigilance uh and effects
and stunts um but it was fun challenging
work and really great to be in Europe
and in Europe with all these guys here I
have a question for Jennifer Jennifer uh
Katniss making her final appearance on
the big screen of all of the films that
you've done has been such a big part of
your
life is there a moment that you have
it's a favorite moment for
cactus all of the movies of all the
movies you have 30
seconds genuinely though you can call a
you can call a Lifeline if you
want um it doesn't have to be just one
but there are moments that popped with
you about catniss there were moments
where you really felt like you're like
just say something anything even if it's
a list
um
god um well
uh I suddenly I can't remember this
whole what about when you volunteer for
your sister that was cool thank you I L
that yeah you're all allowed to shout
out suggestions please I need a lifel um
love you Jennifer thank you that that
does not help her right yeah I love you
Jennifer is not a suggestion it doesn't
help that mind doesn't need any more
Sidetrack um when I first go into the
arena you know when I do what in the
arena the the arrow into the sky that
that was you know not as climactic in
person as you would think
um I don't know well we have our clip
out of context that's fantastic yeah I
volunteer is tribute that's her favorite
of course come on guys the I volunteer's
tribute it has to be your favorite yeah
I'm just you know it does have
to welcome thank
you
good job will I have a question for you
oh my God I got really scared for a
second I can't even I'm blacking out
right now I can't even remember enti
period of these are questions Lion's
Gate gave me by the way so you know I
will not be blamed for these questions
the truth is there is one but it's in
the second movie I don't want to blow oh
really okay just write it down and I'll
say it later Josh huton okay I love this
is actually what it says on my card when
we last left PETA his
memories had been hijacked and he was
not Katniss's biggest
fan that's what it says right
here that's the nicest way to say trying
to choke the life out of somebody yeah
yeah uh so why don't you talk about now
where we're picking up your character
because that was such a traumatic ending
to the last film and now we're starting
in that place with your character and it
I think a lot of people are just curious
where do you go from there yeah it's uh
it's a long road to recovery uh and and
it has some bumps along the way but we
kind of picked Peta up um inside 13 sort
of trying to get his um himself back um
and he he went through a lot and even he
was in the capital was torturing and
using tracker Jack Venom and all sorts
of you know really dark twisted uh
devices to turn him into a kind of a
psychotic weapon against catniss and so
in this in this movie it's really kind
of PETA trying to they're trying to
rehabilitate him to be able to use him
as a as a good guy and kind of help the
cause and you couldn't stay away for
long couldn't resist yeah
this how's it going oh Wow's going the
tension up here with you3 is
incredible uh okay Liam Gail has evolved
he's now part of the district 13
uprising and the stakes keep getting
raised for your character over and over
and over again higher and higher have
you I mean has it been a tricky
Evolution for you do you want to comment
on that or anything You' like to say
yeah thank you for asking it's actually
a great question I'm glad you asked it
it's a lion gate question again thank
you you know Gail's kind of been on the
sidelines for a long time and uh you
know been watching the fight happen and
he's finally you know in the mix and and
heavily a part of the the uprising and
the military operations and um you know
becomes a big part of sort of the plans
and and and ideas behind how they're
going to attack the capital um he he
teams up with Jeffrey Wright's character
Bey and uh they devise a few ways to
kind of Ambush and and uh trap the enemy
it must be fun because as it's obviously
in the last movie and now particularly
in this movie you get the sense you
really get to kick ass which I think
would be a lot of fun I mean you and I
have fought together and we've had a
couple of fights we have fought it's
like a ritual before we go on to your
show we just have a anytime you come on
my show you have to fight con before you
go on you have to fight me uh we both
strip to the waist and fight and uh
that's an appealing half of that's an
appealing sight
uh I I have a question for Willow a prim
triggered the path of catniss everan
story and uh began the whole thing
really and you see this relationship
ship evolving over the films where do
you how do you feel it's evolving in
this next film without giving away too
much um I think that it's evolved a lot
I think throughout every film you see
how beautiful their relationship is it's
really genuine and I think catniss is
her whole goal throughout this entire
series is to save Prim and to be there
for Prim and I feel like you saw a
little bit in mocking J part one I think
Prim starts to be there for catniss more
than catness is there for her in a way
um which I find really interesting and
it's really fun to see how it's evolved
to the to become that like all of a
sudden Prim is really like grown up and
is kind of a stronger character and
she's she's kind of taking care of
catniss in a way more mentally than
physically but you know what I mean she
needs that huh she needs that she does
need that yeah so I mean I think it's
it's been really fun to play because she
really has evolved over
five years now I mean I I started when I
was 10 and now I'm 15 so you know it's
really cool to see how it's evolved I
have to say for me personally I was
watching the LA the last film when you
went out to get the cat I was so mad at
you I was the whole world is coming
apart and you're like I've got to get
the cat I know everybody was like get
another cat a cat are you kidding me
don't do it oh c I've gone down a bad
Road um so many cat people here are mad
at me just go to Hash Conan
cat all right this is a uh this is a
question for all the panelists we get a
little free form here and get a little
crazy and get a little sexy
uh I was kidding about that what are you
most excited to see finished on the big
screen is there something for you
personally why don't we start with you
that you you like it to see resolved on
on this in this final I mean for for me
the the most satisfying and gratifying
part of of the series was was this film
because it ends the story um and so I'm
just excited for for everybody to see
the end of the story to see what happens
to the characters to see how it closes
out and to feel that emotion and that
history kind of come to come to an end
um I'm really pleased with the film I'm
really pleased with the way it with the
way it ends and I I can't wait for you
guys to see it how about you guys
anything that you've personally been
feeling like I you three have been
living in this triangle now for the
whole making of the film are you is
there some sense of personal like I want
to see this resolved in some way just
for yourselves Josh and I have a have a
great scene in this
we yeah we've been friends for so long
but we really haven't worked we haven't
had any SE together in all movies wait
one second
say thought we all do everything about
everybody and apparently there
are know about you were asleep okay what
is it Peter and gu were having a talk
Peter said Peter Cuz you're Australian
Australia it's Peter you really did say
Peter
P I know it just so much who named
someone it is a good it's a really good
question but okay you can get this all
right we have a really emotional scene
together and we we there there might be
a kiss between Josh and
I made my knee react they said no
spoilers man yeah sorry he said maybe
foret give I also I'm excited because I
feel that you know in the stories
leading up to this one Katniss is
always she's she tries she doesn't want
to be a piece in the game that's what
Peta sets out from the beginning and yet
there's always somebody calling the
shots for her um whether it's snow or
it's plutar or it's coin and this is the
story in which she finally takes control
of her own story and takes control of
her Destiny and makes decisions that she
makes for herself not the easiest
decisions at all but I think watching a
character and a woman truly come into
her own and and and make decisions to
set her own course for katas who we've
seen grown up through grow up through
these movies I that to me feels very
satisfying was there a final day was
there a a moment where you guys all
wrapped and realized okay this this is
done now and you were all in the same
place one of those Classic Hollywood
stories where you're all in you're in
Prague you're inad you're in Berlin you
know you're all different places well
you guys were W me me and Josh wrapped
the day before the last day of rap and
then we came to set when you and Woody
had the last day yeah and then we held
each other we had an emotional holding
an hour yeah during during during we
hadn't actually finished shooting yet
but we felt in the need to have a good
hug and there's no way of saying this
that doesn't start rumors but that night
we held each other and slept like
puppies it's true you know it's
fantastic but it was it was great like
afterwards we like we got to like we all
the final rap moment and then we just
kind of moved it this really weird like
old historical building in Berlin and it
was like this back hallway leading this
giant ballroom and you got the whole
crew back there and just gave like a
great speech and I think you tried to
give a speech or something I
didn't no I didn't it was Woody gave a
speech yeah yeah yeah and it was great
uh no it's really super emotional can't
imagine wood he giving a speech that
would be an interesting give a
slur listen everybody you gave an accent
no Francis gives us emotional speech but
that always happens to be I'll listen
and like we're crying and then somebody
will always be like Jen do you have
anything to
say one I can't follow that but what
have we learned over the years about
public speaking don't do it don't do it
yeah I have a kill switch for your mic
under the table
all right we uh we are going to get some
questions from the audience but first we
have a couple of fan questions from
social media yeah
yeah
exactly question to Willow from Twitter
if you lived in panm which district
would you like to live in question mark
or even the capital question mark that's
a hard
question I mean all the districts are
not super fun so I
mean I I feel like I would actually say
District 12 just because I feel like the
people in district 12 are pretty great
like I mean and you already know them
exactly I'm so familiar with them like
we have coffee all the time and so you
know but I feel like they're really like
strong independent hardworking people
that like stick with their families and
I don't know it's just cool like we got
a good vibe going on you know what I
mean like we got a good vibe am I crazy
isn't the place to live President Snow's
Palace well I mean so the guy's a jerk
but it's an incredible house running
water whenever they cut to the district
everyone's sad trying to eat a squirrel
and then you look at snow and he's
eating pudding out of a silver bowl I
thought about that for a second cuz I
was like you know I love food so much
and it's kind of it's I'm I'm split but
um yeah he lives in a five-star hotel
all right I have a question uh this is
for Josh Hutcherson from uh ever's
arrows Twitter a lot of fans would like
to see the books from peta's point of
view would you like
that oh um that' be interesting I think
every character has such like a a
different perspective of the story that
I think there's a lot of characters that
would be cool to sort of explore you
know their inner thoughts like you get
to get inside of cat's mind but I mean
catniss is the obvious choice to to kind
of go through the story so I I'm very
happy that it was done in her
perspective I think each character would
be cool to see kind of their own little
view of the world what's going
on okay question to Liam from
Hemsworth's hugs of
Twitter this question is from me that's
a good hug
down that's my handle
uh if if you could meet Gail what would
you say to him
we say uh it's all right mate there's
plenty of fish in the
[Applause]
[Laughter]
sea and also you work out you look good
yeah what are you pinching Yeah question
to Jennifer Lawrence from uh hutcher
wife
Twitter I told her not to tweet it Jen
if you could keep one of Katniss
everdine's costumes which one would you
choose classic
wifey well I love the wedding dress from
Catching Fire because it's
[Laughter]
understated
I the wet suits would be funny cuz that
would be hilarious to take to a
beach so maybe the W you know what I do
want that's in the that's in the um
Museum and I spotted this it's the
orange backpack from the first Hunger
Games cuz I just have so many memories
of hiding my phone in
there but I can't have it where did you
see it you saw in a museum yeah there's
a there's an exhibit a Hunger Games
exhibit at the Whitney Josh and I win
every day not
Whitney yeah go for your time like hit
the kill switch D hit the
kill uh anyways like gentlemen no they
they actually we we were just there like
a couple weekends ago in New York and
it's like this traveling Hunger Games
exhibit that uh shows a lot of like the
behind the world of PM and like all the
things of the movie and they have like a
bunch of our costum they had a bunch of
stuff that I
wanted doesn't work annoying turn can't
you guys steal stuff if there's
something on the set that you really
want have you taken something like oh I
love the crossbow I can't let it go and
someone's there saying that's me to
first of all it's not a crossbow it's a
longbow crossbows are easy um he has a
crossbow
[Applause]
I have
handcuffs I'm sorry but all I have to do
is pull a trigger I and it's been months
and months training so that I could be
called a crossbow I I uh I stole a
little a little I have those bows I have
my I have my rehearsal well there there
were a lot of different bows when
shooting there's the closeup bow which
is has no scratches and has you know
been J Jennifer proofed and um then
there my the shooting one that really
has all the scratches on it the one that
I caught in the grass and it hit me so
hard in the chin that I flew myself
backwards um then there's the limp one
too the limp the limp one rubber Lim oh
that's easier to pull um yeah and then
there's a rehearsal one just to get used
to the weight and that's the one they
tried to give me as if I wouldn't
notice so you're bitter is what you're
saying very very bit I don't know what
I'm going to do with these artifacts
it's not like I'm going to have them
laying around my house but but yeah I
feel a sense of
ownership uh we have another question
here uh for Jennifer at sassy joshifer
on
Twitter love these handles your
character catniss has amazing braids
throughout the franchise how are your
braiding skills oh
terrible I didn't I have two brothers
and my mom doing hair I I don't I barely
know how right so you couldn't braid
your hair like just if someone said
you've got to braid your hair you'd be
like there's nothing I can do I can I I
could braid in an emergency situation
like this is a life or death situation
Jen can you braid your hair can there be
a lot of Fly
[Laughter]
Away uh okay and then this question to
all cast from @ everlark Sunset
Twitter can you do them mocking J
whistle Al together
[Applause]
please I got to be honest every time I
try and do it it comes out as like the x
file xile
yes like
[Music]
exactly can somebody help
me I doing it really well over here
that's very is that you you're eerily
good at it unless you have a Cage bird
with
you I haven't done this in a really long
time I don't think my character ever
does this there's like 5,000 people I'll
just say yeah now you're just doing
it and it's feeling creepy yeah do your
Josh has a cool skill
dud I've heard that when I tell jokes
sometimes
uh
recently it's good got a plethora of
animal how do you find out you could do
that what took you to know you could do
that lots of time on my own yeah yeah
not many friends a dog I've been there
all
right we have some audience Q&A now
let's go to the audience we will answer
your questions a light's coming on I'm
told this has all been worked out love
you hello how are you yeah go right
ahead hi um um my questions for the
whole cast um I was wondering that since
you finished filming months before how
was it going back and filming the epilog
oh well we finished filming we're all
best friends you're my I'm your best
friend all we still see each other all
the time um but it was really fun that
we shot in the field where we shot the
first scene and I cried that day and
went up to Francis like I just thought
about rapping the movie and it was like
day one of like 3
150 um and Josh was playing with my
nephew and I was
holding she has a bear's adorable little
baby we were like running around the
field anyway it it was really it emal
was there and that sucked yeah that was
most emotional part for some reason I
thought that Liam and I don't know why
yeah I guess I don't know we had some
additional photography to do and we had
to film it months after we finish the
main shooting and and under my ignorance
I was assumed that the whole cast was
going to be I was going have grab the
microphone I really like it though I
feel like a
rockot and then and then uh it was just
really it was really a let down one all
of a sudden Woody wasn't there and get
of the Britney Spears
microphones
so yeah it was
emotional okay next
question hi um first of all it's honor
to see you guys thank you so much for
coming out I think we all appreciate
it um my question's a little similar but
I'm wondering how much of like the from
the book is in the for the epilog like
how is it film CU I read that the last
scene is like just catniss don't don't
don't don't don't
switch
switch okay actually is it similar to
the book or is it a little different
like how is it made kind
of it's all green screen no I'm kidding
we uh I mean we look we made we made the
books I mean you know things change in
adaptations so there there will be some
you know differences but we we always
wanted to make the books we made the
books I think everybody here who loves
the end of of the last book is going to
love the end of this movie um really
really
emotional I think you guys are going to
be really happy good good answer
fantastic all right uh next question and
I I love your purse I think it's
fantastic Miss Lawrence this is an
honor miss
lawence my question is do you think any
of the characters you play rubbed off on
you I
wish um
um there
yeah yeah my the drinking really rubbed
off on me from American Hustle um I'm
joking
um I would like I know I
see um no was just a reminder here that
they put here for Jin specifically I
think that says Please be aware that
many MERS of your audience may be under
18 years old I love how that's just like
Josh's he did that to me earlier he
pointed he's like that's for you like
what um I would like like to I would I
would hope that a little bit of cadis
rubbed off on me in a way just in the we
had similar I mean nothing about us is
similar CU she's Brave and I'm an
actress
um
but but in then sense of something kind
of falling on you or not falling on you
like a big
piano I'm trying to say what I have in
my head is actually pretty pretty
interesting there just no way I'm going
to be able to get it out um come on come
on something was kind of bestowed upon
Katniss in a way in the same way that
saying yes to these
movies was unto
me and
um I would like to hope that some of the
leadership something I don't you guys I
haven't done interviews for like a year
I'm really out of practice this is our
first so hard way to dive back in dude
I'm so sorry I thought that was really
nice what you were saying yes I thought
that was really nice the sense
that you're too hard on yourself I know
no I know they making fun of
me keep going I I would hope that you
know C sorry I'm sorry of any of them if
anybody rubbed off on me I would hope
and think that it could possibly maybe
CICS thank you for your wonderful
question I sorry for my horrible
answer it's a great answer uh next
question hi uh my question
is is for Francis and Nina um in mocking
J there is a there's a lot of material
in between the climax of the book and
before the the epilog what were the
challenges that you faced in adapting
that section of the
book um Francis was like I don't
know I'll take a little bit of that and
then Francis you dive into I I think one
of the biggest challenges was that in
the book um cace doesn't know a lot of
what's going on around her during that
segment following the climax prior to
the epilog there's a period in which
she's somewhat in the dark and so you
can't leave your
hero passively in the dark um waiting
for news and so we needed to find a way
to uh stay with her as we've tried to
throughout the series we've always tried
to see things through her eyes and and
to stay rooted in her point of view um
and uh to let an authentic emotional
response evolve and give ourselves time
to do that while at the same time being
mindful of the fact that uh you you want
to keep driving forward towards your
conclusion so finding that balance
between taking time for real emotion and
having the kind of a propulsion to drive
towards the end I think that's been a
challenge um but I feel great about
where We've Ended up and wanting to feel
that you feel true emotional resolution
for these characters they've been
through so much our fans have been so
sort of committed to their journey and
we we want to come for it yeah I mean I
thought of less less as a challenge and
more kind of an interesting Journey
because uh one of the things that I've
always been really interested in the
books is the idea of the the consequence
of war and violence and you know toward
the end of this movie that's what we're
really exploring with Katniss and so to
be able to sit with
her and watch her sort of put herself
back together as best as she can was
really interesting to me um and really
satisfying and so Le less of a challenge
and more fun in a weird way
um good question though next
question hello hi um I'm okay sorry I'm
just really happy to see you guys um
we're happy to see
[Music]
you do that voice
man you know I've said that to people
and no one
reacts usually
run okay my question is what are you
guys going to miss the most about
filming The Hunger Game series you're
looking at it
a no I mean I don't know for me it's
been like the for me it's been like the
uh the the most incredible movie making
experience and then just experience in
my life of of getting to know these
people and and across the board just all
just all such lovely people and and
sweet angel he's a sweet sweet angel
your
fingers but no really like like from
like the entire not just like these
people you see here but there's so many
people that were involved in making
these movies hundreds and hundreds of
people people and they were all great
like all the cast the grips the people
who do all the effects you know the
cameramen everybody all the cast the
extras they were all so into making
these movies and just genuinely great
people and getting to meet them and work
with them uh was incredible and and and
so I'm definitely going to miss this big
family that we've created and we're
going to like a lot of us are still
going to see each other but there's
still like hundreds of people that we
became very close with that we're not
going to get to see anymore and then
that's uh that's definitely hard I
think another
question
hey
guys um so this is like a really
powerful story and I just wondered if
there's one thing that you hope fans
take away from this last movie what
would it
be this is all you
Jen my worst nightmare I don't know but
I heard my name at the other did you say
Jen I was like maybe I misunderstood and
he said me
um I
think so got it you got it you got it
just relax
Focus take a second Liam will you say
hello to me or what you just say to that
girl it's okay J it's okay J it's okay
J just got worse and worse D don't ask
me to do that again I I don't want to be
a part of your stuff over or just help
me what I'm trying to say
start power the power of you know of our
future is in our hands I'm trying to say
that I'm a not cheese that's great it's
a good message yeah you see how hard
this is God it's about Hope and
empowerment I'm saying yes about Hope
and empowerment also you know being
involved you know this was this was oh
oh at the beginning of this movie this
was one girl who was standing up to
something huge and gigantic this
entire what I what I like about these
movies is that they take the entire
world in a way and and and condense it
into this one continent and an or
however you want to say it but all of
these issues are very real and she was
one girl it was very scary and she took
it into her hands and she did what was
right even though she knew there was
good I mean I don't think you should
risk her life but um I was just about to
say even though she knew she could die
and then I was like well pum pump pump
great
um the power of the
future is with you and in your hands
it's
true I I I will also say though that I
think um and it's something that
I
I will say I I will say to uh in an
answer to that question though that
there's there's something that that
happened at least for me uh you know
when there's certain scenes that we
would start to shoot um and you just you
feel the history of the characters and
especially of catness and so to have to
take away the sort of payoff of reading
the books and stories and seeing the
movies and to feel the emotion and the
history and the theme and the ideas kind
of all come together and conclude at the
end I think uh is is really powerful I
mean I I even felt that just shooting
some of the scenes and I I really hope
you all uh are able to share in that
feeling I think we have time for one
last
question oh the audience just said no
so each and every one of you could test
yes we'll get to all of you we brought
sleeping bags
yes you all know to say
that Miss Jennifer Lawrence I just want
to ask you how did Jennifer Lawrence bid
goodbye to catness
ever
a I don't really feel like
it's happened yet I don't I I still it's
such a huge part of my life you know
these movies
really did change my life I mean these
the the as Josh was saying you know the
people that are in my life are
still you know you guys challenged to me
did I love you um are taking oh okay I
thought you were turning it
off
um I think that the the changes that
happened in my life in doing these
movies are so permanent and still with
me that I don't think that I'll ever
really kind of say goodbye to always it
feels like a a part of
me all right uh that was really the all
the time we had for audience questions
oh she's in a full-blown catniss out oh
you're in a catus outfit I'm sorry
is I'm
sorry and besid I thought you were a
common fan of the bow and arrow I got
conf
they do exist I'm sorry go ahead yes my
question is for Josh and Jen it could be
open to the whole cast though how is
your character's Attitude Change change
the way you portray the
character well Peta kind of goes
crazy uh so there's that um and uh I
it's my first time really playing crazy
uh and I've always wanted to I don't
know what it says about me but uh like
um but yeah so I mean I I got to have to
I had to really like let loose and and I
don't really yell at people ever so I
never really yelled at someone and in
this movie and in Ma J 1 and to there's
a lot of really intense moments that I
had to really push myself towards or
places I've never even gone to in my
normal life um and now I have to do it
on camera with a bunch of other actors
and people standing around it's going to
be judged for the rest of my life so
it's you know it pretty intense but uh
yeah it was fun to kind of let that
crazy out and and it gave me confidence
in the future if I need to kind of go to
extremes and everything like that that I
have done it now and I know how to do it
yeah um at the beginning when I first
signed on to these movies I was 20 now
I'm
24 um um but I was I remember feeling
frustration yeah
seriously um but I remember feeling
frustration about Katniss's hesitation
to kind of be this hero I remember
reading them being and and doing and
wanting her to
be excited about this role and to take
you know and I I remember just kind of
being like why is she and then as I kind
of grew with her I realized
how real and also powerful it it was her
hesitation to start this war because it
doesn't solve problems sometimes um and
so I can't remember what your question
was but I remember thinking this could
possibly answer
it so I hope that that is in fact true
okay anyone else sound
good all right I've been uh I've been
just uh handed a note you've all saw if
I wasn't it was here
already this just in I totally believe
that
okay P it out of here yeah uh I've been
asked to ask you guys if you'd like to
see the trailer again before we
go roll that trailer he what's that the
bait the
bait standing right here we're standing
on a giant Bas speaker and that was that
was incredible uh I want to thank all
the panelists uh for joining us today
they are not only incredibly talented
people they're incredibly nice and very
real and you should know that they are
as they appear so let's have a hand for
our
panelists look at that movie November
20th go to hashtag unite # mocking J
part two #
sdcc is that I don't know how to say
that uh there's also uh I will prompt
all of you to visit the Lionsgate booth
on the convention floor for giveaways
and to attend Talent
sightings thank you all for being here
you guys are an incredible audience
before we stop I was kind of say we
we've uh you know we've been doing these
now for 4 years and uh the fans have
been insane and you guys have been the
best and there's been so many moments
where we're so tired on these press
tours and everything and you guys always
show up with so much energy and support
and we just know we all feel the same
way we appreciate it more than anything
and uh we're so happy to see all you
guys today and just thank you so much
thank
you
thank you thank you to us how cool is
that thank
[Applause]
you I think this is the part where we
awkwardly stand and walk that way I
believe and now the awkward standing the
[Applause]
waving